france qui s'enorgueillit d'être le plus
long bateaux du monde était aussi le
plus confortable et le plus beau est
allé se faire admirer pour la première
fois cette année en méditerranée les
gens heureux vous le savez n'ont pas
d'histoire et non patchées nous aussi
notre ambition est de vous inviter à
vivre la belle aventure que fut pour
chacun sont croisière en vous proposant
ces premières images de vacances et non
en les noyant sous des flots de
commentaires
sachez seulement que pour ne pas
succomber aux bavardages leur péché
mignon
les animateurs de la rtf présents à bord
s'obliger à fréquenter un peu chaque
jour le monde du silence
[Musique]
sur ce monde flottant chacun qu'il soit
américain français belges canadiens
suisses comme les passagers de cette
croisière
chacun trouve le jeu qu'ils préfèrent on
y échange des balles sous le moindre
prétexte et le film gangs en état et les
seuls pigeons que l'on y rencontre son
d'argent
[Musique]
à l'exception toutefois des pigeons que
mijote avec des petits fois le chef
grangier cordon bleu de la mer et grand
responsable des cuisines
enfin j'ajouterai que pour les
nostalgiques de l'information il y a
toujours entre les repas quelques
journalistes à se mettre sous la dent
[Musique]
et puis grâce aux commandes en repart il
y a les escales
cette année le france parti de cam n'a
relâché à palerme au pirée et a-rod où
nous venant d'arriver ensemble
[Musique]
e
il s'agit de débarquer plus de 15 cents
passagers dans les plus brefs délais et
les vedettes s'y emploie
[Musique]
en kit france avec un peu de regret et
on découvre une robe avec ravissement
nous allons accoster et vagabonde et
a-rod en compagnie non seulement des
passagers mais de guy bedos et de sophie
daumier qui ont choisi france pour un
voyage de noces
[Musique]
voici le couple le plus jeune et le plus
sympathique du cinéma français
[Musique]
et voici les vieilles ruines et vieilles
pierres de l'île où les visiteurs
d'aujourd'hui sont reçus par le soleil
et sont accueillis avec le sourire
[Musique]
après rod c'est beyrouth et les
excursions organisées comme à chaque
escale la plus courue de ses excursions
conduisant les passagers de france à
baalbeck ou le cameraman de la tv pour
passer inaperçu c'est déguisé en
belphégor l'acropole de baalbeck et
l'ensemble le plus vaste et le mieux
conservé de l'architecturé romaine c'est
temple dédié à jupiter vénus et bacchus
ont été construits au 2ème et 3ème
siècle de l'ère chrétienne
[Musique]
c'est là décor choisi par des
photographes parisiens pour faire des
photos de mode
[Musique]
et
il
[Musique]
là
après le liban et israël mais le canon
die femme est braquée contre personne
les israéliens ne souhaite que vivre en
paix
[Musique]
israël au printemps seiler embaumé par
les fleurs d'oranger c'est un pèlerinage
qui nous conduit au pied de saint jean
d'âcre où errent encore parmi les
vieilles pierres les fantômes des
croisés et puis à capharnaüm où parmi
les touristes nous retrouvant des
français bien vivant et bien sympathique
nos amis pierre mendy et pascale robert
[Musique]
diard mendier pascal robert qui sont les
interprètes avec guy bedos et sophie
daumier dannatt de feydeau jouer sur le
théâtre de france qui n'est pas encore
la comédie française en même temps qu'un
acte ionesco
et puis voici les eaux du jourdain
paisible et voici nazareth où jésus vécu
son enfance et où une basilique
dissimule et touche aujourd'hui la
grotte de l'annonciation
[Musique]
ans
oh
enfin à travers la campagne d'israël
césar est doux saint-paul embarqua pour
son dernier voyage
césar et où les vestiges de l'époque
romaine voisinent avec les palaces
construit récemment par les rothschild
[Musique]
[Rires]
oh
bakou
après ce groupe folklorique israéliens
sur le chemin du retour par le détroit
de messine
une rencontre attendue le stromboli un
volcan qui daignent encore fumer au
passage des cheminées de france
[Musique]
à
on
cependant à bord de france chaque soirée
soir de gala
on y rencontre des femmes les plus
élégantes les artistes les plus en vogue
et les lumières de la ville que la
compagnie générale transatlantique fait
briller sur tous les océans
[Musique]
josé artur il représente la radio france
i ni le cirque et gérard s'est-il music
hall parmi les cotillons alain du chemin
président du groupe de paris animateur
de la croisière et guy bedos et sophie
daumier
[Musique]
et la vie parisienne sur un rythme
d'offenbach
car ne vous fiez pas à ses images france
est un ambassadeur
il passe impassible sur tous les océans
et se contente d'en porter tous les
coeurs dans son sillage
[Musique]